Mary old England just had a coronation
over the weekend maybe you watched it
maybe you saw the plumes and the robes
and the carriages and everything I don't
have much to say about the coronation
obviously the United States broke away
from England some time ago at the UK
broke away from my church it's not my
thing I get it but I did watch the
coronation
and
I I did enjoy large parts of the
coronation there were many many faults
to find with it there were many many
faults to find with King George there
are many many faults defined with what
has happened with the royal family and
with the UK in general but in a world
that is so fanatically opposed to
tradition How could a conservative not
celebrate the coronation of the king of
England